(upbeat instrumental music)
- Hello Hong Kong, thanks
for hanging around.
I will try to deliver.
One thing I've been thinking a lot about
as I've been spending time
walking the conference hall
and spending the day today in Hong Kong
is just the diversity in the audience
of where we come from, what
we're trying to achieve.
And I gave a lot of thought to,
what do I really want to
deliver in this keynote?
How do I bring value, I think,
one of things that, you know,
when I think about products or services
and definitely when I
speak or create content,
how do you bring value?
Like, what's the trade here?
I'm getting your attention,
I want to bring you value in return.
The thing that really stands out for me
is the one thing that I'm confident in,
the one thing that I'm
absolutely confident in,
is what attaches all of us.
What is the one common theme?
Whether you're a start up,
whether you're a professional,
whether you're a student,
solo entrepreneur,
large company, starting tomorrow.
What is the one thing that guarantees
a connection point that
we can all agree on
and get value out of the
framework that I create here?
And I think that comes
down to one simple thing,
that no matter what
you're doing in this room,
whether you're trying to
raise money for a non profit
or you're trying to
sell a thin tech product
or trying to raise capital
for what you're trying to achieve,
the one thing that we all trade on
in this room is attention.
If you're not sitting and
debating, on an every day basis,
on how you as a human or as a company
act like a modern day media publisher,
how you communicate,
whether in written, audio,
or video form, and then which platforms
are under priced and over
priced, you're basing,
missing the punchline.
It doesn't matter how
good, bad or indifferent
your product or service is
if nobody knows about it.
You're vulnerable.
And the thing that I'm curious about
is where everybody in this
room is on the life cycle.
Because if you've had success
for three or four years
you might've fallen in love
with what got you here.
The biggest concern I have,
and I see some heads nodding
already, is what got you here
today is always the thing
that's not gonna get you to tomorrow.
For example, for me, if you ask me today,
what am I most paying
attention to, where do I see
the next arbitrage, it's
absolutely around audio.
I'm obsessed with what's
going in the U.S. market,
not only around podcasts,
and this is global,
but especially around
what's going on with Alexa
from Amazon, Google Home, and
the future Apple Home Pod.
The one thing I promise you is
that every single person here,
besides the health and
wellbeing of their family,
and money, values time.
And time is emerging very quickly.
If you take a look, and
this is extremely prevalent
through the Asian market, European market,
South American market, U.S. market,
time's value is exceeding
on an everyday basis.
As we become more busy,
we start valuing time
tremendously, tremendously.
That is what Uber, and
other transportation apps,
have traded on, it's saving you time,
even the perception of time
is a good business model,
but the thing I think
I'm very fascinated by
is how much sound and audio
will be selling back to you
time founded that you used to not have.
When you watch a video, which
I think we can all agree,
video content is scaling in importance
and is absolutely in the
prime of its medium right now.
When you're looking at video,
it is taking up your time.
Audio is incredibly passive,
and so the thing that
I'm trying to force down,
energy wise, in this
keynote, is the following.
Number one, no matter
what you do for a living,
you need to think of
yourself as a media company.
Your company, if you are a SAS tech,
you are a media company comma SAS tech.
If you are a consumer social network,
you are a media company
comma social network.
If you're a human being,
you are a media company
comma human being.
When you wrap your head around that,
you start understanding
what you should be doing,
which is, in your natural way,
producing stories for people to consume
to bring awareness to what you do.
So one, if you are not
taking this opportunity
for what it is, you've already
put yourself in second place.
This is the moment.
Number two.
Entrepreneurship got popular,
and that means it's dangerous
because there's a lot of people
that raised their hands that
have entrepreneurial tendencies
and aren't necessarily entrepreneurs.
Just because you say
you're an entrepreneur
doesn't mean you're a
successful entrepreneur,
and the reason I bring
that up is not to be like
I'm cool, you're not, or
anything of that nature.
There's just one very important thing
that is not being discussed enough.
We talk about working smart and having
the right strategy and
having the right product.
I'm stunned by how much pushback there is
when I talk about working hard.
There is no.
Zero people you know that have
built a successful business
without working their face off.
There are people that
have inherited money,
there are people that
have had that dynamic,
but you know nobody, nor does the world,
that has started from zero and
built something substantial
that hasn't put in a
disproportional amount of work
to get there.
It is the one utterly
controllable aspect of our game,
and if you really want this,
please really start thinking
about maximizing every minute.
That doesn't mean neglecting your family.
That doesn't mean neglecting your health.
But I am stunned, as
somebody who is spending
an enormous amount of
time in this ecosystem,
by how many people have the ambition
and their mouth is running
to what they're going to accomplish
and their actions don't map to it at all.
- Hope everybody's ready for
this session because I am.
Gary, how you doing?
- Yes, I'm doing well.
How are you?
- Great.
- Hello, Hong Kong.
(cheering)
Hello, Hong Kong.
- So basically we're
talking about, you know,
when you have fear, you just
don't give a shit about it,
just go for it.
- Listen, everybody's, I'm
petrified of my mother's health,
like petrified,
so I have fear.
I just think life's about alternatives.
Life's like, I don't give a shit
when people talk to me about theory.
It's binary.
Like when your spouse gets terminally ill,
theory doesn't matter,
you have to navigate.
When you lose your biggest
client that represent.
How many people here have businesses
that have very large clients
that represent big
portions of their business?
Raise your hand.
How many people here have a client
that represents more than
50% of their business?
Raise your hand.
I mean that's fucking
scary for these 11 people.
Like their businesses suck.
Like they need to, like one
more time for the 11 of you.
I want to give you a piece of advice.
You need to, like tomorrow,
like you should leave
this talk right now, leave,
and start getting other
customers because that's scary.
Like who wants to be that vulnerable
to something that they don't control?
You know, so for me,
like there's just things
that you can't control.
If the 11 of them lose
that client tomorrow
because the decision
maker that is their client
goes to a different company
and the new one doesn't
like them or has a sister
that has a similar business,
they're in panic mode.
They've got to adjust.
And so, you know, you know how
many people here's businesses
rely on somebody that is not them?
It is scary how many
people's businesses here
that the most important person
to the business is not them,
that it's a sales person,
that it's a technical leads co-founder.
It's somebody else.
That is scary,
and so there's a lot of
things we don't control
when we build our businesses, the market.
Don't even, listen, I'm a boy
that's born in Soviet Russia.
You start thinking about markets
where you have to be
nice with the families
that run the country, fuck.
Right?
there's a lot of things
we don't talk about
that make it scary,
which is why I don't
like the current state
of entrepreneurship in the world
because it seems very
party and popular and cool,
and it is literally everything but.
I started my daily vlog.
Yes, I like attention and I want selfies,
but much more because I
want people to see how hard
it really is, how long every day is,
if you really want to
be successful, and so.
I'm scared of everything,
which actually, ironically
means I'm scared of nothing.
- Right that is.
- Do you understand?
- Yeah, I got what you mean.
- It's like got it?
I know it's a funny little statement,
but by accepting fear of everything,
it kind of makes me numb and
makes me not fear anything.
- [Woman] Anything, yeah.
- What is your advice
for young entrepreneurs
in college that are
trying to start businesses
and run them themselves?
- Quit college.
- [Man] Quit college?
- I'm probably, I'm probably.
If you're actually an entrepreneur, yes.
Because I promise you
college is doing you zero
for entrepreneurship.
You cannot teach entrepreneurship
in a college environment
because it is an unbelievable reality
of like you have to navigate
it to know what to do.
Are you collecting debt?
- No.
- Okay, good.
Well then you just have
to decide, you know.
Look, what I would tell you to do is,
you know what I would tell you to do,
if you were my brother, if you were AJ,
I would say you've got to make a decision.
Either you realize that these
are the last couple years
that you can really, really, really enjoy
and not do shit and enjoy them,
or you could put all your
energy into your business
and let your grades go to shit
and either get kicked out
or let them push you through the system.
If, you know, you have to also understand,
my definition of an entrepreneur
is a little bit different than
I think a lot of people's.
My definition of an entrepreneur
is you can't breathe
other than when you're
running your business.
- [Woman] Hello.
- Hello.
- It's me again.
I'd like to thank you so much.
First of all, I've been
watching your talks,
your videos, a lot in the morning
because my mom never supported me
and I had to hear and watch somebody
that will give me this push and.
- I get it.
- [Woman] And thank you so much for that.
I really appreciate it.
- I will tell you, and I
apologize for cutting you off,
I was so supported by my
mom to be an entrepreneur
and I want to remind people,
and this is a great
crowd to understand me.
I was an immigrant.
If you're an immigrant or you
come from immigrant parents,
education is the way out.
Every Russian, Jewish boy and girl
that came from the Soviet
Union with my parents
was getting straight A's
on their way to Harvard.
I was getting straight F's.
So for my mom to have the self esteem
to not care what the
other parents thought,
to let me do my thing, was such a gift
that I now produce
content on a daily basis
because I feel guilty
that I had it so good
and I want to provide that for you guys.
That is why I do it.
And so I think the biggest thing
that you need to understand is
the best product will always
win if people know about it,
right, and so I think the thing
that I spend a lot of
time on is I'm a marketer,
I like to market, I understand marketing,
I'm a business builder,
I've built businesses.
I think there's an incredible interesting
kind of graph between the
quality of your product
and how many people know about it.
So for example, if you're a great marketer
and you listen to everything that I say
and you get a lot of attention
and your business isn't working,
a lot of times it happens to
do with your product sucking.
You know, like we don't spend enough time
talking about the product
or service you're selling,
you know, so please, if
you're sitting in the audience
and you're looking for the magic pill
or you think that you're going to be able
to siphon some information that's going
to allow you to play in
the edges of the arbitrage
of opportunity, please
make sure you're looking
at your product and service
to make sure it delivers
because if you follow my blueprint,
if you get results from my ideas
that you then become an executor of,
if your product sucks,
all that I'm going to do
is expose your product faster
and you're going to go
out of business faster.
So please start there.
But after that, please
understand the following.
The is a golden era of
marketing for one simple reason.
The places where our attention
and our consumers' attention
are, are now driven
by marketplace bidding dynamics,
not by writing an upfront
check to get the ads.
Please understand this.
Please understand that the
biggest difference for us,
as communicators, is we don't
need millions of dollars
to do television and print
and outdoor and direct mail
to hit mass.
We are trading on marketplaces,
Google, Facebook, Snapchat.
These are biddable marketplaces.
The reason this is the best time
is because those marketplaces
are under priced.
Those marketplaces are
under priced right now
because the biggest companies in the world
are not spending enough money on them.
You have to understand, when
there's a come to Jesus moment
and the biggest brands in
the world properly spend
in everything that I talk about,
everything I talk about
becomes null and void.
We are ridiculously lucky because we get
to navigate through this time.
For anybody over 30, and
especially if you're over 40,
you really recognize that,
because for the over 40 crowd
in here, we lived pre
internet in a lot of ways.
The scale is remarkable.
The impact is high.
The upside's enormous.
And to be very honest, I think most of us
are just taking it for granted.
I don't think we understand the impact
of how much the opportunity is real,
and for me, it becomes
disproportionally compounded
because you're actually
at this conference.
You're actually part of a very small,
interesting group for me,
which is I know how
big the opportunity is,
I know that 99% of people
have no idea it's happening.
You do, so you're part
of 1% of the whole thing
that understands it's happening.
Now it's yours to lose.
I would argue that if you
are not able to achieve
what you want to achieve in life,
and you're at this
conference during this time,
then you really mis-executed,
then you really got into the things
that I worry about when I put out content,
which is you worry way
too much about stuff
that does not matter, that
you're worried way too much
about other people's opinions,
which is the biggest reason
you don't take chances
because you worry about how
people judge your failures.
Then you're doing a lot of other things
that are leading to
huge levels of mis-shots
and missed opportunities.
And so that's why I speak so much
about being insular,
having the right intent,
because literally, fundamentally,
if you synthesize
everything I've just said,
non-action is the fundamental reason
that most of you will fail,
at this point.
Being in this room, at this conference,
during this time, and understanding
quite a bit of what's actually happening.
Non-action, which if you take all the way
to the seed of a human
being, is insecurity,
which is probably the biggest
reason that I create content,
because I hope that you use
me as your shield to do shit.
Period.
Most entrepreneurs in the U.S., which is,
oftentimes, not always, because
of cultural differences,
but oftentimes you get to see a preview
of what's happening before it happened.
When I think about my friends
that have built successful businesses
in Southeast Asia, by
simply paying attention
of what's happening in America
and then replicating some
version of it in the market.
It is literally the dream come true.
You know, American entrepreneurs got mad
at those brothers in Germany, right,
who had ripped off the
ideas and built a business.
I always was so upset about that.
I mean I think Facebook has proven
that there's no ripping
off if it's a feature.
And I think I would also argue
that ripping off by looking
at a different business
in a different market
and then interpreting it
into your market is far from ripping off.
I think it's called smart.
So I would highly recommend,
I don't know if it's pride,
which I think holds back
a lot of people, but please take advantage
for the disadvantages one
could think they have,
there's only five million here.
If you want to do it in Indonesia,
there's a lot of people, but
there's so many micro-climates,
so that's, you know, so many
different segmentations,
mainly in China.
Whatever you would deem a disadvantage,
please understand you have
the greatest advantage,
which is 90% of things
are human, not cultural.
90% of things are human, not cultural.
If you're capable of
understanding the culture
of your consumer and
layer the cultural context
on top of the human thing
that is happening in America,
you are halfway home.
An unbelievable advantage
to be an entrepreneur
in this region and watch things play out,
by the way, for free,
no report needed, no
hiring Boston Consulting
or Bane and McKenzie,
by reading and watching
videos and downloading apps,
something that I don't believe most people
in this conference are
taking full advantage of
or respecting enough of how
big of an advantage that is,
and to me, very honestly, I'm
quite selfish when I speak.
I dream in three years from now.
You email me, nothing
would make me happier
than getting an email from somebody here
who said they had a 50 million dollar exit
because you know they just
looked at what was working
in America and they built
the replica-ish of it here.
Please do that, please understand
how big of a deal that is,
and I would argue it is your
singular biggest advantage
in this market to be able
to be shown what will work,
and then allow you to interpret it,
oftentimes with very
little change in the model.
Cool?
Cool.
So those are some of the
top of the funnel things
that are really on my mind.
I continue to execute, I continue to do.
I'm very fascinated by how much time
people spend dwelling and debating.
I think we glorify strategy
and we underestimate execution.
I feel like if you look
historically and rewind
the biggest successes, the
strategy came from the execution
and you did some Monday
morning quarterback.
I'm a real genius in hindsight
because I can manipulate how
I got there after the fact.
I'm going to talk about so
many things in different ways
than the intent that was at first
because you don't even
realize that your strategy
came from it because when you're doing,
the strategy's happening in real time,
you almost forget why you were
doing it in the first place,
and so I promise you,
indecisiveness and debate
and pontificating, and ultimately ego,
is stopping so many people
from being successful.
- [Man] Hi, Gary, my name is Terrence,
and I'm 20 this year.
So just one question for you.
I've been listening to
you for about a year now,
and I'm just trying to figure out,
as a 20 year old without any experience
in my parents' business, I've wanted to do
a video blog, an audio podcast,
but I don't have the
experience to actually do it.
So which should I focus on?
Building up the experience in the business
or should I go direct to
help market the company?
- Well listen, if you started
a podcast and a video blog
about being experienced in
the craft, that would be bad,
faking it, but if your podcast was about
the experience of learning the craft,
you'd probably have a lot of
20 year olds following you.
- [Man] Okay.
- So I don't think it's
about getting the experience.
When I talk about I built
a business for 15 years
before I came out, right,
I say that because that's what happened,
but I have a funny feeling if the internet
was around when I was a kid like this,
I might have started documenting
my journey right away.
I just wouldn't be
walking around like I was
a business building guy,
I would be talking about
being a young, ambitious guy
who used to sell baseball cards
and now I'm about to do it for wine,
and I would take people
along with my journey.
That's my biggest problem with people
that don't have experience, they're lying.
They're lying that
they're business experts
or my favorite, you're a
20 year old life coach,
because, you know, you've lived life.
So to me, I think you
can start the podcast
and the video blog.
I mean I wish I did that
because I, there was,
I probably cried, cried,
50 times in the first 10 years
that I worked with my dad
because they were very painful fights
and that would have
been incredible content
that I wish you guys could watch
if you're in a family business
because it turned out okay
and it would have been really
cool to see how that happened
and why and how i was able
to give more than I took
and how I loved my dad more than the money
and how I thought about what
I could do in my 30s and 40s
and it's okay to lose in my 20s,
but I wouldn't have walked around
and said I was a marketing genius
because I thought I was gonna be.